wow patch 1.10 oma duck and beliefs
happy mein haus ist ein bisschen leute
als youtube hat man manche momente wo
man zum beispiel viel zeit hat so wie
ich als student gerade den
semesterferien ist und lust hat ein
video zu machen aber nicht so wirklich
eine idee und was macht man dann
dann schaut man selbstverständlich mal
auf der trend seite nach was leute
gerade so interessiert und dann schaut
man sich das an und überlegt ob man
damit vielleicht arbeiten kann und dann
denkt man sich so okay okay ich kann auf
jeden fall nicht irgendwelche battle rap
machen zehn stimmen fehler ich jede
beziehung ruinieren können vielleicht
auch nicht macdonald sprengt mit einem
cent stücken bezahlen würde ich
persönlich auch nicht machen weil die
leute die bei mcdonald's arbeiten
vielleicht nicht den allerschönsten
beruf haben und es hat keinen sinn macht
den leuten ihren beruf noch schwieriger
zu machen und deswegen was sie wir hier
um mein gott react to german youtube das
tue was könnte man da machen vielleicht
auf amerikanische youtuber reagieren
unfassbar innovativen format was die
welt bereichert ich weiß sollte aber ich
glaube es könnte echt witzig werden ich
habe mir von euch amerikanischen über
vorschlagen lassen es gibt glaube ich
nämlich recht viele von euch die auch
amerika nicht überschauen und
wahrscheinlich sogar mehr als ich
deswegen danke für die vorschläge
okay was haben wir hier liter coach und
david dobrick ok alles klappt es darum
ein gibt und auch direkt vis-a-vis
dieser name ist und zum release akku ach
du scheiße 67 millionen abonnenten hat
in der domstadt news alter schwede okay
das können uns direkt
[Musik]
okay die kommt doch recht untypische war
behielt über rennens video nicht so
meine lieben oder haben die bienchen
sondern so christoph matschie
aber ich finde eigentlich ganz
sympathisch gehen
[Musik]
die ist ja richtig geil darauf deute die
macht auf mich den eindruck als wäre das
so meine traumfrau weist die sonne
richtig gestörten humor wisst ihr wie
ich drauf bin ihr wisst dass ich auch
gerne einfach mal aus prinzip scheiße
mache und allerdings schieße dream on 28
mal so viele abonnenten wie ich kann man
noch zusammen sein also des videos kam
eine minute alt aber das kann man sich
schon gut leben da ist das waren oder
sich gerade ja erst mal etwas richtig
sympathisch aber hat die ganze zeit so
das wäre so als würde ich durch
genetisch sprache reden sowie das schaut
sie auch kein ja aber dass diese
übertriebene art hat so ein bisschen
nervig wir haben noch eine andere und
zwar okay 2,6 millionen abonnenten dass
es so krass das gibt es so viele
menschen da draußen mit zig millionen
abonnenten von denen noch nie gehört
habe ich sind wahrscheinlich alle selbst
einfach millionäre durch youtube und
hier darf nicht davon gehört so mal
schnell millionär gewordene youtuber
gehen wir zum best kasse preis erwarb
das ist auch ein thema für mich leute
ich bin nämlich auch weiterhin auch
darauf der suche nach dem auto schreib
doch mal die kommentare welches auto
denkt ihr passt zu mir
versucht bitte auch ein paar ernsthafte
antworten dazu zu geben
das für ein haushalt alter der haushalt
ist durchaus ungewöhnlich würde ich
sagen uns die beste preis er war mein
gott ich dachte er würde im auto kaufen
hallo nicht gemacht war kalter wir sind
die braut okay da wird doppelt wirkt auf
einen wie jemand der eine relativ
verrücktes leben hat ist wie sieht aber
so aus als würde in so einem irrenhaus
wohnen kein normaler ruhiger mensch
[Musik]
okay was wird noch vorgeschlagen or
crack pipe okay
das ist echt nicht schlecht da das soll
so nur südamerikanischer familie in
amerika sein und ich finde der akzent
vom vater ist richtig gut getroffen das
klingt mega authentisch
das ist richtig geil alter mégane als
drei tage später okay was haben wir hier
haben wir eine person die auch schon für
howard punkt euro vorgeschlagen wurde
und zwar cameron der aussendung schreibt
euch einen tweet und sagt du nie was
macht ihr hier sagt natürlich ja
reaction to crazy in cross youtube views
das klingt nicht an kämpfern ich wollte
mich noch video von mir anschauen aber
und sowas hat halt so viele klicks ich
das verstehe ich nicht nur menschen sind
ziemlich abstoßend die letzte person die
vorgeschlagen wurde ist die person die
wir in den trends gesehen haben die das
auf englisch gemacht hat aber klappt
sunny heißt die da kommt sogar wisst ihr
was jetzt macht man heute wird träger
jetzt mal alle leute die sagen 'oh mein
gott' youtube geht den bach runter
heute laden keine stundenlangen
abhandlung über die metaphysik der
sitten hoch youtube ist zu ende
um diese leute noch mehr zu triggern
react diesem video auf ein video in dem
sie
die videos von diesen mega abgegangen
die hat sonst zwar 30 40 tausend klicks
aber die einfach so 700.000 was man auf
jeden fall merkel ist dass sie wirklich
aus norwegen kommt wird jetzt einen
komischen englischen akzent in germany
react to me please bitte for the family
schreibe das doch einfach mal leute
sie zeigt nicht nur jack russel reaktion
in diesem video also sie ist halt
vielleicht einfach so der ruhigere typ
su wei oma duck and peace happiness is
on fire
sie macht ihr ding recht guten versagen
dafür dass die 160.000 abonnenten halte
ich habe auch nur 300.000 also wir sind
jetzt nicht so die giganten auf youtube
die alles perfekt machen müssen die hat
so ein bisschen komischen norwegischen
akzent und ist nicht so mega so
übertrieben amrum schreien aber
eigentlich gibt es nicht da eigentlich
müssen leute rumschreien in ihren videos
sonst schau ich ja nicht mit youtube
from alles klar wenn sie diese
kommentare
aber leute wir sind in der rollator
jetzt schon bei sechs stunden ja wie
kamen dass an dieser stelle wirklich
gefallen hat das gerne kommentar da wir
von vorne folge haben wollt dann
schreibt in die kommentare welche
youtuber ich mir als nächstes anschauen
soll bis zum nächsten mal haut rein
macht's gut und so kann man video auch
mal beenden